c'est une jeune femme de 28 ans elle vit
dans cette petite maison à hambye la
libé un quartier populaire
d'antananarive avec son compagnon parti
pour quelques jours et son petit garçon
de 6 ans toulouges qui dort encore à
l'heure où nous arrive
elle héberge aussi une fillette de 12
ans qui l'aide pour le ménage et va
chercher son fils à l'école quand le
travail auquel il est 5h30 et angeline
se prépare pour conduire son fils aîné
koné aller travailler
angélina quitter la campagne avec sa
mère quand elle était enfant sa mère est
décédée quand elle avait 15 ans elle
s'est retrouvée seule dans la ville
tombée enceinte
abandonné par le père de son enfant elle
a connu la rue avant d'être accueillis
par l'association réunionnaise aena qui
lui a offert une formation et lui a
trouvé un travail
c'est beaucoup
[Musique]
bonjour qui m'a dit bonjour
les bons jours
[Musique]
4-0 relativement résiliente et vous
voyons qu'ils aiment et ateliers payer
me liénard est loin de là vous savez
[Musique]
parfois on m'a demandé ça avant de
partir travailler
angéline nous fait faire le tour du
propriétaire mais moi et pas les imiter
t2c canada marc as mangé à la tête un
homme fait des pays qui paye combien
pour le pour la maison dix cantons et
mina dieu par mois lâche amer le
compagnon d'angelina lui travaille comme
agent d'entretien et gagne 30 euros par
mois
ensemble le couple dispose donc d'un
revenu mensuel de moins de 80 euros
[Musique]
sur le chemin de l'école angéline
s'arrête pour acheter un goûter en
chemin elle nous montre aussi des
toilettes publiques
car si sa maison à l'eau courante elle
n'a en revanche pas de toilettes lcd
l'eau parle pas du coin
oui toi y et cela malgré ses faibles
revenus
angélina décidé d'inscrire son petit
garçon dans une école privée car le
niveau de l'école publique reste très
faible à madagascar
elle paye pour cela 5 euros par mois 10
% de son salaire
[Musique]
j'espère que c'est fini l'upi dans tout
ça et après il fait le clown il alors je
veux informer tous les jours
angéline va travailler à pied il lui
faut une demi heure pour rejoindre le
centre d'antananarivo
[Musique]
depuis quatre ans j'ai dit il travaille
comme femme de chambre dans cet hôtel
très côté de la capitale
ce matin elle doit nettoyer la chambre
la plus étonnante de l'hôtel la
décoration est originale le prix est
raisonnable environ 50 euros la nuit
mais c'est à peu près ce que gagne
angeline pour un mois de travail
je trouve que c'est un bon salaire en
fait un outil militaire
c'est pas pour les petits
il ya des gens qui payent le même prix
pour passer une nuit ici à l'hôtel
dans des situations comme ça elle se
sent triste
d'un côté elle aussi de la personne
puisqu'elle a le moyen mais d'un autre
côté elle est triste en plus que des
fois elle voit des gens qui pensent que
la chance de pouvoir pour faire des
caprices
alors que si c'est elle qui avait la
chance elle aurait dû s'en servir pour
payer le loyer ou pour acheter des
délais nourriture
kouadio tisca rhodia me fait mal au
nepad qu'elle faisait mais rami après sa
journée de travail nous retrouvons
angélino marché quelques centimes d'euro
pour des carottes ce n'est pas cher mais
quand on gagne 50 euros par mois
le budget nourriture est très saine tu
vas vraiment beaucoup
[Musique]
l'avion de 7,3 me c'est le filet de jeu
la viande ce n'est pas tous les jours
nous déçoit le vaccin
[Musique]
je
à
cet avis elle est comment le difficile
et dur et difficile autour du cou attend
les rhénans soleil et dans une ambiance
aux serveurs fujitsu
[Musique]
angéline rêve de retourner à la campagne
dans la région de son enfance
en attendant mardi elle ira voter pour
l'élection présidentielle
comme la plupart des malgaches ce sera
juste avec l'espoir d'une vie meilleure